the rumor mill was turning but Ubisoft
has finally confirmed our suspicions
there will be no new mainline Assassin's
Creed game in 2016 according to CEO Eve
gilma the year off will let the
developer quote take advantage of all
the new technologies Ubisoft clarified
that this move does not mean the
Assassin's Creed series is moving to a
biannual release schedule instead each
game will be individually evaluated for
release the studio stated since the
release of Assassin's Creed unity we've
learned a lot based on your feedback
we've also updated our development
processes and recommitted to making
Assassin's create a premiere open-world
franchise we're taking this year to
evolve the game mechanics and to make
sure we're delivering on the promise of
Assassin's Creed offering unique and
memorable gameplay experiences that make
history everyone's playground we might
not be getting a mainline Assassin's
Creed game but there's still plenty of
assassin goodness in 2016 all the games
in the Chronicles trilogy are available
as of this week and the Assassin's Creed
movie is due out this December and if
Ubisoft announces anymore for 2016
you'll hear about it from gamespot
Oh